if you're selling your home you might
get some interesting offers here to help
us navigate the home selling waters is
harvey blankfeld with las vegas real
estate now who is sponsoring this
segment great to see you nice to be back
i know people are getting offers from i
buyers what is it i buyer okay and i
buyer's a company who's going to buy
your home you've heard of all the big
brands open door offer pad zillow and
then there's even some smaller local
companies who do it too and basically
they're offering you cash for
convenience hey we'll pay cash you don't
just show you have to do anything we're
going to give you cash for your house
but ultimately what they're doing is
they're not buying it because they
really want to live in it obviously
they're going to flip it they're going
to turn it over they may invest some
money into it and then sell it or they
may not even invest some money to insult
for a higher price retail so what i
liken it to is you're selling it to a
wholesaler who's going to then sell it
retail why not as a seller if you want
to make the most money just sell it
retail and use a use a realtor use a
trusted realtor well walk me through
this i'm selling my house for i listed
first i'm listening for 300 thousand
dollars zillow comes i'll give you cash
i'm like all right cash done and why
should i come you because you would tell
me the upgrades i need to do well yeah
there's a handful of things you that
could happen i could come in and say hey
jc put six thousand dollars in and fix
up that kitchen and paint this this room
and i can get you twenty thousand
dollars more as a result of that
investment that's something i can help
you with the other thing is is that with
if if if your house is worth three
hundred thousand at a retail level
they're going to come in and off you 265
okay because they need to get retail
they can't they're not doing it to lose
money although they have been losing
money as a matter of fact zillow just a
few months ago went out of business on
this thing they pulled away and now
they're going back to what they used to
do there's not flipping homes anymore i
didn't know zillow was in the home
buying business i remember them they're
the site i go to see how much my
neighbor's house is what house is worth
yeah zillow started as a as just a nice
portal for consumers to use to find
homes and then they converted over to
became a brokerage and then they became
an eye buyer but they they got they did
it for about three years and they
realized they were losing too much money
doing it where's the market going right
now the
price is still on the rise prices are
still going up there's still lots of
demand right now for houses uh interest
rates uh we we think they're going to
continue to creep up a lot tiny bit not
a lot but they think they will creep up
and that might slow the appreciation
rate but the appreciation is still it's
still pretty steady we're about 15 to 16
percent year to year right now last year
we had a little over 20 so it's still
going up we got about 30 seconds
someone's out there first time home
buyer what do they need to do to get in
the game okay if you're a first time
home buyer there's a handful of things
first of all get a good realtor because
you're going to need the experience i
mean you know there's so many creative
things i can do to help you get the home
more than just offering more money
sometimes it's not about money it might
be about terms or the way you're
presenting the offer and that can
sometimes put you over the top and get
you the home you want that is huge news
right there it's not about the monies
about the terms and stuff you can do
harvey you're always full of great
information i appreciate it thank you so
much thank you thanks to las vegas real
estate now for sponsoring this segment
for more information about harvey go to
his website has all kinds of great
information
lvrealestateradio.com or give him a call
at 702-203-1165